finalmente el presidente estadounidense
Joe biden hablará aquí en la copa 27 en
charmershake pero no tiene un discurso
nada fácil por delante y es que
recordemos que sus aliados europeos de
la Unión Europea ya lo instaron de
manera muy sutil a que tenga acciones
más ambiciosas pues tanto Úrsula
wonderlayen la presidenta de la comisión
europea como el mandatario francés
Emanuel majul dijeron que era hora de
que sus aliados occidentales tuvieran
estas acciones se espera que el
presidente vayan aproveche este discurso
para defender la ley de reducción de la
inflación en la que incluyó 370 mil
millones de dólares para reducir en un
40% de aquí al 2030 los gases de efecto
invernadero que emite ese país pero por
el otro lado Estados Unidos ha sido el
país más contaminante en la historia y
Hasta ahora ha cumplido pocas de sus
promesas de financiación como lo
recuerda un nuevo reporte de en el que
dice que de los 100 mil millones de
dólares anuales que prometieron las
naciones más industrializadas en 2020 de
Estados Unidos solo aportó 8.000
millones de dólares antes de llegar a
Shake el presidente se reunirá con Abel
fata el presidente de Egipto y los
Derechos Humanos son el centro de esta
discusión especialmente la situación del
activista Cibernético a la app el fatá
quien desde el domingo comenzó una
huelga y dejó de consumir agua además es
un tema bastante espinoso porque el
servicio de prensa de Egipto para los
corresponsales Internacionales envió
justo hoy un poco antes de la llegada de
bailen un comunicado en siete idiomas
distintos y con 12 páginas en las que
tiene 12 publicaciones en Twitter de
este activista además tacha su cara con
una x y pone un letrero donde se dice
que es un instigador a la violencia a la
matanza y turismo esto es un poco el
abrebocas de lo que le espera al
presidente